saudi arabia's crown prince mohammed bin
salman is visiting turkey for the first
time since the murder of a saudi
journalist plunged relations between the
two countries into crisis the crown
prince
today met with turkish president recep
tayyip erdogan in ankara both men say
that they want to mend ties that have
been strained since
journalist jamal khashoggi was murdered
in the saudi consulate in istanbul back
in 2018.
now you may remember that u.s
intelligence concluded that the salty
crown prince probably ordered the murder
of khashoggi in 2018 turkish president
erdogan blamed khashoggi's murder on the
highest levels of the saudi government
and he launched a global campaign
against the kingdom's leadership now
he's calling the crown prince his friend
so why is erdogan so desperate to
normalize relations here's dw
correspondent dorian jones in istanbul
well it's necessity turkey is facing
regional isolation having effectively
upset nearly every leader in the region
and this is part of a wider policy of
resetting those relations we've seen a
similar approach monitors with the
united arab emirates with egypt and
israel but in many ways saudi arabia is
seen as key this is not only a regional
power but turkey is looking for its
financial support president erdogan is
in charge of an economy that is in
crisis inflation is officially eighty
percent but most believe it's well over
a hundred percent and the and the
currency the turkish lira is under siege
with warnings it could face a further
crash and erdogan is believed to be
looking for major financial support from
saudi crown prince bin salman
to uh tie over its economy until next
year's elections where erdogan faces
re-election
that was dorian jones reporting there my
next guest tonight was closely connected
to the work of jamal khashoggi
karen atiyah was khashoggi's editor at
the washington post where she herself is
a columnist karen is also the author of
say your word then leave the
assassination of jamal khashoggi in the
power of the truth that book due out
next month karen joins me tonight from
dallas texas karen it's good to see you
again um
there's a lot to talk about here but
first i just want to get your reaction
to
the this visit by muhammad bin salman to
turkey today
yeah i mean
what is there to say
except
this is
something that
he feared obviously from the
um the moment we heard that dama uh had
been
killed um
just we always wondered um you know from
our purchase at in washington you know
just how far was turkey really willing
to go
uh for somebody um who yes was close to
erdogan but uh you know saudi arabia you
know as your report rightly said being a
a huge power in the region
you know it's it's just it was just a
matter
perhaps of time i mean that's the
cynical look at it but um what i think
about right now
is just the
horrific message um that this uh
you know um new renewed friendship sends
to the dissidents to the um journalists
to those who have uh found turkey to be
um or istanbul to be a place uh that
they can gather and gather during my
reporting i met with a good amount of
um
arab saudis who had fled to istanbul
because they felt it was safe and now
basically the message is out you know
you can be killed
uh kidnapped and eventually wait a few
years uh
and
you know nothing will happen
you look good we've heard arguments
that
realities have to take president here
that it it's it's time to to move on and
get on with the business of geopolitics
is it
yeah this is something i
addressed in in my latest column for the
post
there's this
idea right that you have geopolitics you
have so-called realism
um you know another thing to consider
with saudi arabia particularly when it
comes to the us is the us is looking at
saudi arabia to be a partner with
trying to normalize relations with
israel and so you always have this uh
these arguments that say well we need to
balance human rights with freedom
uh sorry with national security and with
realism and i think i would argue to
think that this is separate from
geopolitics to think that that basically
um journalists
uh anyone who speaks up um that that is
not a matter of of
national security or not or that that is
not a matter that um
really frankly leads to
insecurity i think it's quite
unimaginative frankly
in your piece today in the washington
post
you ask will president u.s president
biden push our allies to respect press
freedom when he visits saudi arabia next
month for example and you answer that
with
one sentence i'm not holding my breath
why
i mean uh
jamal's case uh jamal was also a u.s
resident right
um and i think that you know from the
reporting we're seeing here you know as
you said
it's looking like administ the
administration as well officials within
the administration here are saying well
this relationship can't be um held
hostage to to the khashoggi murder but
i've long said that this what happened
to jamal was more than just what
happened to him it was also an awakening
to saudi arabia's actions in yemen to
the
u.s support of the war in yemen and it
really was
not a bump in the road it was a tipping
point in questioning um u.s pretty much
unconditional support um for its allies
regardless of who gets killed so it it
sends the message against west
journalists as well
that we are not safe if we happen to be
targeted by one of our allies
in the middle east
your new book karen is about
this murder and
the power of the truth and i'm wondering
what do you say when someone asks you
you know what condition is the truth in
in this case khashoggi's family for
example they're still waiting for
justice aren't they
um and we
we all are there was a reason why um his
case uh his situation was so
uh in a ways you know we weren't just
fighting for him but again fighting for
um all the activists all of the
journalists who
um who jamal even himself uh stood for
in writing in his columns in in the
washington post
so you know to
um i i think you know obviously
we're not going to let you know my
government or the government of saudi
arabia or turkey um forget uh about
their actions um in this particular case
because it is um so much about um just
how far
uh countries and governments are willing
to go
uh to maintain relations and to preserve
their power and i don't think that is
something that um we can never forget
yeah and that's what we are trying to
make sure
does not happen for sure
karen t as always karen we appreciate
your time and your insights tonight we
look forward to your new book as well
thank you
thank you so much